christliche mission für die einen ist
die dass herrschaftsinstrument das vor
200 jahren den kolonialherren diente
ganze völker zu unterdrücken
für andere ist die unaufschiebbare teil
der christlichen identität und auftrag
zum wohle der menschen mit meinen drei
gästen diskutiere ich darüber ob und wie
mission heute vertretbar ist
meine drei gäste das sind sabrina müller
evangelisch reformierte theologie die
zur zeit an der uni zürich zurkirchen
entwicklung forscht das ist leo becker
der leiter der international christian
fellowship einer der größten
freikirchlichen bewegungen der schweiz
auch ihnen herzlich willkommen und ihnen
auch ein herzliches willkommen benedikt
schuberth evangelisch reformierter
pfarrer in der stadt basel
lasst sie mich gleich mit ihnen beginnen
herr schubert sie haben zehn jahre lang
in angola gelebt sie waren dort
theologischer lehrer
sie waren ein foyer ein gesandter eines
missionswerkes das alles kann man ihrem
lebenslauf im world wide web entnehmen
aber ich finde nirgends den begriff ist
so nah ist es ihnen unangenehm als nicht
so nachricht zu bezeichnen mir
persönlich nicht aber ich denke der
begriff des missionars ist so stark mit
dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
kommentierten wir leben mittlerweile im
21ten dass ich froh bin dass es andere
begriffe gibt
ich erinnere mich aber auch daran dass
wir in der zeit in angola
selbstverständlich von der angolanischen
kirche als missionarisch willkommen
geheißen begrüßt wurden
die hatten gar kein problem damit leo
becker sie bezeichnen sich selber auch
nicht als missionar öffentlich zumindest
so nicht aber wieder die bezeichnung auf
sie zutreffen
ja und nein es ist die mir die frage was
man da unter diesem wort steht das ist
da ein großer begriff auch behaftet mit
vielen geschichten und auch erlebnisse
von denen würde ich mich nicht ganz wohl
fühle mit diesem namen war leben das
immer mit geschichten und erlebnis schon
verbunden ist und würde ich eher sorgen
ein aufhänger müllers sie forschen zur
kirche entwicklung und mir scheint
korrigieren
falsch lägen der begriff der mission
liegt wieder in der luft das ist ein
zentraler begriff bevor geworden
hat das auch oder ist das auch ein
ausdruck der krise der kirche also
weltweit ist es schon länger wieder ein
thema es hat sich auch viel verändert
emissions- begriff ich denke aber schon
dass es auch ein ausdruck ist der vielen
fragezeichen die die kirche hat was
sehen wir überhaupt noch als kirche wir
haben nicht mehr eine stellung mitten in
der öffentlichkeit in ihren am rand was
ist überhaupt ein auftrag der kirche was
ist der auftrag von religion von glaube
und damit kommt das thema mission so
wird auch wieder zur sprache
bei ihnen allen dreien habe ich jetzt
explizit oder implizit den begriff der
veränderung gehört sie sind froh dass es
andere begriffe gibt sie haben
angesprochen dass es problematisch
behaftet ist derbe hilft der mission
wo denken sie entstehen die leute ganz
allgemein heute haben die immer noch
diesen blick der mission der sich ganz
stark an die koloniale vergangenheit
europas anlehnt m in der schweiz bemerke
ich das thema noch sehr stark schweiz
deutschland auch mission ist häufig noch
ein rotes tuch davon gesprochen wird in
meinen vorträgen auch in den dingen die
ich veröffentlicht habe ich viele
kommission aber es ist ein rotes tuch
ein rotes tuch nur bei den kirchenfernen
leuten oder auch bei leuten die in der g
auch bei leuten in der kirche
warum das da kann ich nur vermutungen
anstellen spekulieren
ich denke es ist ganz stark genug für
hofft mit dem 18 19 jahrhundert der
kolonialisierung und irgendwie haben wir
es zumindest im deutschsprachigen europa
verpasst den ganzen diskurs der mission
mitzugehen und die debatte weil in den
letzten 70 jahren ist dazu ganz viel
gelaufen
der begriff mission die geologie hat
sich massiv verändert und wir haben das
was passt und stecken irgendwo noch
zwischen dem achtzehnten und neunzehnten
jahrhundert sie haben vorhin etwas
schmunzeln müssen als sich die frage
stellte ob es denn auch kirchennahe
leute sind die mit diesem begriff
ein problem haben warum denken sie dass
das so ist die haben ja offenbar diese
veränderung auch nicht vollzogen ja also
da gebe ich dir ganz recht sabrina die
die ganzen entwicklung die wir in den
missionswerken und in die
missionsgesellschaften in der mission
theologie gemacht haben die ganzen
überlegungen die neukonzeption von
mission was auch in der internationalen
kirchlichen gemeinschaften nachgedacht
und reflektiert oder das ist irgendwie
nicht bis zur basis durchgedrungen
auch nicht bis zur pfarrerin und fordern
in den kirchen die sich jetzt nicht dass
biografien gründen ohnehin für die sache
interessieren
also ich bin wirklich erstaunt dass für
viele auch kollegin kollegen vision
nichts anderes ist als eine form von
unstatthafter unmoralischem eingriff ins
fremde eine art geistliche
kolonialisierung
wie würden sie denn ganz persönlich
jetzt mission definieren für sich ich
übernehme eine definition die meine
akademische mama einmal welt geprägt hat
obwohl sie nie festgeschrieben hat sie
sagt mission ist die theorie und praxis
kirchlicher fremd begegnung das sind
sehr nach kirchlicher sprache genau aber
es geht im schlicht die im grunde geht
es schlicht darum dass man sagt die
kirche lebt in einer welt mit menschen
zusammen die in ihrer mehrheit ihren
glauben nicht teilen und die kirche wird
also auf jeden fall mit diesen menschen
kommunizieren auch schweigen und der
rückt den rücken kehren ist eine form
von kommunikation und mission ist die
frage wie wir diese kommunikation
gestalten
das ist glaube ich auch bei ihnen im
isaf
eine zentrale frage dieses gestalten der
kommunikation
zunächst aber wie definieren sie sich in
ihrer gemeinschaft den missions- begriff
ich glaube wie gesagt dieses wort
mission nicht gerne weil es ist etwas
was man das gefühl man stirbt das
menschen über
und da das immer schafft das haben heute
auf der nase sitzt egal welche religion
und da mal gesagt ich bin kein missionar
ich kann nicht etwas überstülpen aber
für mich ist es ganz ganz simpel wenn
ich von gott begeistert bin ist es nicht
normal dass ich das andere
ich behaupte sondern ich erzähle ist da
wo ich es erzählen kann nur menschen
auch diese frage stellen
und da wo leuten in das spiel habe leute
warum nicht mehr darüber reden dann
natürlich dann wieder auf und das ist
etwas völlig eben ein ganz natürliches
dass ich zu meinem glauben zu diesen
werten stehe das kann man nicht trennen
darum ist für mich geben das wort
mission komisch zu gast man macht etwas
mit etwas über mich ist wir sind eine
gemeinschaft wir sind begeistert von
gott und wenn man begeistert ist hat das
über eine auswirkung und das ist für
mich vision und was auch immer ist kommt
dass eine begeisterung aus das lässt
sich etwas machen muss etwas ich bin
wenn ich mir jetzt vor augen halten dass
es oftmals sie alle sind in städten
tätig mehr oder weniger und beschäftigen
sich vor allem auch mit dem urbanen
menschen also hat dieser urbane mensch
ein größeres bedürfnis nach
spiritualität nach dieser form von
begeisterung vielleicht erstmals ziele
pkw
wie schätzen sie das ein jeder mensch
ist spiritueller mensch hat die frage im
leben woher komme ich wohin gehe ich und
die frage muss jeder mensch beantworten
darum das ist nicht weniger geworden
oder mehr geworden sondern diese frage
muss jede generation jede kultur stellt
sich ganz ganz einfach diese frage und
und darum ist es für mich ganz natürlich
über diese werte zu sprechen und haben
eine eine eine kirche dass sie bei uns
immer leute geht und und erzählt ganz
natürlich nicht überstimmt und nicht so
quasi mann ist ein wärter aber
heutzutage ist eben mega verteilt wenn
man sagt man die leute bequem regen
etwas aber wenn ich begeistert bin vom
neuesten produkt von mcdonald und seine
kollegen haben es muss du unbedingt
probieren kann man auch sagen das ist
missionarisch würde man nie sagen was
ich nicht glaube ist und im glauben sagt
immer einfach das ist eine natürlichkeit
dann leute begeistert sind von gott von
der bibel kann ich nichts dazu sagen
kann
ein einfaches beispiel ich spiele ab und
zu golf und dann fragen leute was
arbeitest du dann sage ich fahren und
dann ist bei der alten nächstes gespräch
beendet und die alten warst du bist das
ist gar nicht so aus erzählen
ist nass mission missionarisch oder
nicht dass die frage ist wirklich sagen
ich glaube gut das ist privat geht dich
nichts auf das ist natürlich die die
fragen erzähle ich dir abblocken
die las ich dann die haben ihre meinung
schon gemacht lassen sie mich bei dem
beispiel mit einer fast food kette noch
einmal die die den gedanken aufnehmen
werden für glauben und religion wie für
ein beliebiges produkt ist das etwas mit
dem die sich auch identifizieren können
nein nicht werben für ein produkt das
sehe ich nicht aber ich würde mission
auch nicht mit der werbung gleichsetzen
kommission ist martin keller hat mal
gesagt die mutter der theologie und
steht am grund und ist eines der komplex
ist den fragen der theologie mit ganz
vielfältigen aspekten und so würde ich
sagen es hat nichts mit werbung zu tun
wobei leo bickel ja auch erwähnt hat es
hat was mit leben zu tun und mission als
praxis und leben und auch theologie eine
religion für mich sagen
wie sehen sie das die schuberth sie
haben das weiß ich aus einem vorgespräch
eine eine kritische haltung wenn sie den
eindruck bekommen
an einer stelle wird glaube vermarktet
und jetzt eigentlich zu einer mission zu
einem marketing strategen
ich glaube ich glaube mit dem begriff
produkt kann ich nichts anfangen weil
der glaube kein produkt ist das
evangelium ist ein produkt es ist es ist
das hast du gut gesagt es ist
begeisterung es ist die der umstand dass
man von dass ich weiß ich bin von etwas
ergriffen ich bin von etwas dichtungen
ich bin von etwas fasziniert und dass
ich davon erzähle und da verwende ich
denn den vergleich ich hätte jetzt
weniger weniger als irgendeine einen
einen hamburger hatte ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwie szene verwendet
aber es geht um das selbe dass wir nicht
von etwas begeistert bin dass ich dann
ja meine bekannten und die um mich herum
auch die das vielleicht nicht
interessieren ihn sage hier weil ich
habe so was großartiges da musst du mal
reinhören
und ich denke damit hat es zu tun also
mit dieser mit dieser begeisterung es
muss aber notwendigerweise denke ich und
das ist heute das hat sich noch
deutlicher verändert als als früher
es muss in gewisser weise gedeckt sein
vom leben also mich geht es für mich
geht es darum dass das menschen wenn ich
wenn ich jetzt als auch als auch wenn
ich meine ich zu dass professionell aber
wenn ich wenn ich vom glauben sprecher
wenn ich gerade menschen über an
abdankung oder hochzeiten erreiche die
sonst ja nicht üblicherweise die kirche
kommen dann muss ich dinge sagen wo sie
hinter mir hinterher fragen können ihr
was bedeutet das für dich im alltag und
es muss in dem sinn muss muss ich auch
dann sagen können wie ich das oder jenes
element des glaubens umsätze als auch
die ganz großen grundbegriffe wie gnade
oder sünde oder vergebung das muss
erfahrbarer wirklichkeit sein und die
menschen müssen von mir hören können was
ist für mich bedeutet ich bilde mir
damit nicht ein
das sei das was die christliche
theologie zum thema sagt aber ich
versuche doch persönlich rechenschaft zu
geben wenn sie alle von der begeisterung
sprechen und dieses bedürfnis haben
diese zu teilen dann geht das sehr
glaubwürdigen gibt es aber auch viele
christen und christinnen die zwar zu der
glaubensgemeinschaft gehören in der
sozialisiert worden sind aber die spüren
diese diese begeisterung in dem finden
nicht würden sie trotzdem sagen jeder
christ und jede christin ist per se auch
dieser mission oder sie sind diese
missionsauftrag unterstellt wenn etwas
nicht erlebt erlebt worden ist dann
etwas nicht begeisternd ist dann ist es
immer etwas mega komisches dann sagt man
lieber nichts was meine haltung weil
wenn ich nicht mit einem konter so
gesetzliches kommt abstrakt daher und
leute stehen gar nichts von was man
spricht und der glaube an gott ist fast
dynamisches das ist was lebt
die gäste etwas erlebt haben angebote
für die für den nächsten tag und dann
wirklich ein wunder
und dann dann ist das etwas was ich
erzähle weil ich habe gemacht das würd
ich erzähle es heute ich war die meinten
uns erleben kein wunder denn dann muss
man heute habe ich wenigstens den
glauben gekommen dass gott auch für das
geschaut hat also durchaus innere
doppelte wird com entweder geschieht es
wie ich es möchte
das sieht dann ist das optimal immer ist
nicht so geschieht hat gottes auch
aneinander ob gemacht aber dennoch es
lebt die mir ich gehe schon mit dem
schlaf mit dem bewusstsein gott erhöht
das gerät also auch an ein kann eine
erholung seien aber es lebt ihm ihren
selben gelebt wird dann ist es nicht
etwas was man überstülpt sondern etwas
was eben menschen begeistert und für
mich sind zu viele kirchen sind einfach
man geht dahin dass man erlebt dass gar
nicht mehr das ist eine meiner gründe
und ich glaube dass viele kirchen sind
leer weil weil es lebt nicht mehr man
dreht von irgendetwas aber es ist eben
gelebt und dann ist eben das wort vision
eine katastrophe sabine müller
wie sehen sie das gilt für sie der
missionsauftrag im sinne der kirche oder
im sinne eines jeden einzelnen einer
jeden einzelnen christen aber ich würde
eben zuerst einmal zurückstellen das hab
ich mir jetzt überlegt bei mission sind
während automatisch dahin gestellt haben
es geht darum zu leben und zu erzählen
und das versetzt mehr oder kinder immer
ein bisschen bauchweh weil ich denke
mission ist eben viel mehr und das macht
das thema so spannend zu komplex zum
beispiel die anglikanische
weltgemeinschaft definiert mission
anhand von fünf merkmalen und dazu
gehört auch der einsatz für gerechte
soziale strukturen der einsatz für die
schöpfung diakonische dienste wie auch
predigen verkünden taufen und lehrern
also diese ganze breite oder und ich
denke wenn wir von mission heute
sprechen
da können wir nicht mehr nur die
einbahnstraße und ich sage jetzt mal der
evangelisation und tönen und gehen und
wenn ich das so breit betrachtet mit
diesem breiten missverständnis ist es
eben auftrag immer von einzeln aber die
christliche religion
seht ihr das in bewegung und auch das
kollektiv es ist eines das ist mir bei
der recherche aufgefallen dass diakonie
also die hilfstätigkeit und verkündigung
eigentlich immer gleichzeitig genannt
werden dann aber auch wieder ein
gewisses spannungsfeld bilden die einen
sagen es ist auch mission im sinne der
diakonie also des helfens unterstützen
entwickeln möglich ohne die verkündigung
und für die anderen geht das gar nicht
wie sehen sie das ich habe manchmal ein
bisschen den verdacht dass wenn man die
verkündigung und den tisch wischen
dass man damit es sich einfach einen
teil der schwierigkeiten vom hals
schaffen möchte ich glaube dass ich
glaube dass es sehr schöne traditionen
gibt einer ganz wortlosen mission die
die in einem ist in einem selbstlosen
auch gleich mal für andere besteht wo
menschen explizit darauf verzichten
irgendeinen druck weiter zu geben weil
sie sagen die gelebte liebe reicht das
denke ich dass das ist legitim
ich glaube aber dennoch dass wir in
einer welt leben in der es immer wieder
auch die erklärung braucht und es
braucht ein erklärendes wort warum tust
jetzt lassen warum tust du das nicht und
dass diese rechen noch einmal diese
rechenschaft glaube ich sind wir auch
schuldig aber der dt dieser klassische
die klassische frage welches gewicht hat
verkündigung welches gewicht hat
diakonie dass dieser eine der
klassischen kurzformen dessen sind was
was mission bedeutet das wird ständig
ausgehandelt und wenn ich jetzt an die
institutionen geschichte in der schweiz
denke an die institution bis 23 mit der
ich jahrelang verbunden war dann war das
eine ständige debatte wie wird was
gewichtet und es ist eine debatte die
einerseits geführt wurde
um das wesen der mission zu klären und
andererseits auch geführt wurde im blick
darauf wie wir in die in die
gesellschaft hinein kommunizieren
es geht manchmal schlicht um
mittelbeschaffung und dann ist die frage
ich habe manchmal flapsig gesagt es ist
für straßenkinder die preference mädchen
ist es einfacher gelder zu bekommen als
für eine theologische ausbildung aber
was für das was unsere der auftrag ist
unsere ganzen gemeinschaft was in dem
moment entscheidend ist das hängt nicht
davon ab was sich leichter verkauft
biobäcker sie haben eben erwähnt dass
die kirchen die landeskirchen die
etablierten kirchen an mitglieder
verlieren ihre kirche ist eine kirche
die seit 20 jahren besteht sie haben
gerade jubiläum gefeiert und zumindest
in den ersten 15 jahren rasant an
mitgliedern zugelegt
sie haben wir ein ganz eigenes konzept
wie sie auch gerade eine bestimmte
alters ein bestimmtes segment ansprechen
und wir schauen uns jetzt einen kurzen
einspieler an ein beitrag aus dem film
rock wunder und heiliger geist von bea
moore und dieser welt nußbaum
es ist die generation welche die
traditionellen kirchen verloren haben
junge leute zwischen 20 und 30 jahren
bei sap in zürich wird der gottesdienst
als spektakel inszeniert mit
christlichem bock und religiösem karaoke
kiew heißt international christian
fellowship es ist die größte freikirche
der schweiz jedes wochenende strömen
gläubiger in scharen in den industrie
hangar um dem gottesdienst beizuwohnen
vor 15 jahren wurde die mega church scf
in zürich gegründet
sie wächst seither stetig und zählt
heute 15.000 mitglieder in 33 städten
europas
der film ist einige jahre her
meine frage an sie sabrina müller wie
kommt das bei ihnen an sie sind das
konzept dieser art des feierns des
gottesdienst feiern sind dass konzerte
die sie auch mit bedenken für kirchen
entwickeln auf jeden fall also ich denke
wenn wir weltweit schauen sind das
konzepte die wir mit bedenken müssen wie
auch die pfingstbewegung die momentan
die schnellst wachsende bewegung kirchen
sind genauso wie die bewegung des new
moon ist ich sehe also neue monastischen
gemeinschaften die ganz traditionelle
funktionieren was ist das zb zum
beispiel gibt es in england aber auch
der last exit neue monastischen
gemeinschaften nur leute zusammen in
häusern leben topzeiten gebeten haben
familie willi klos in einen löslichen
gemeinschaftlich gewählt mit familien
gibt es auch in der schweiz monika
müller auch dass diese verschiedenen
bewegen
und jetzt führt die leute die die reise
fand spricht ist dass ihre form des
ausdrucks des glaubens wo ich immer
zurück folge ist die reflexion und die
differenziertheit wobei ich das jetzt
momentan nicht beurteilen kann bei den
bewegung oder oder bei meisterwerk schon
lange nicht mehr
aber ich glaube in einer pluralistischen
gesellschaft brauchen wir pluralistische
ausdrucksformen von klagen spiritualität
wenn sie von reflexion eben gesprochen
haben dann kommen wir auch nicht umhin
uns mal kurz mit diesen bibeltexten zu
befassen die grundlegend sind für die
mission
da ist zum einen in matthäus 28 der fans
darum geht hin und mache zu jüngern alle
völker tauften sie auf den namen des
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geistes
warum dieser fair sowie doch eigentlich
wissen jesus 11
ist hat nicht gekauft da ist also doch
diese bekehrung drehen und nicht einfach
nur dieses begeisterung teilen sondern
dieses aktive bekehren und taufen
was ist was ist an dem fall
das ist meine grundfrage weil ich weiß
oft auch gefragt dass sich doch falsch
man darf das nicht machen zu nehmen was
ist daran falsch es gibt für mich keinen
unterschied ob man leute zwingt oder ob
man begeistert das ist ein himmelweiter
unterschied genau da die strategien und
was geht und was nicht bei der mission
darf kommen wir noch zu sprechen aber
was mich jetzt interessiert ist wir
wissen aus der forschung und aus dem
biblischen texten dass jesus selbst
nicht gekauft hat und trotzdem die
letzte anleitung die ergibt ist geht hin
und her es heißt dieser dieser vers der
große missions- befehl ist 90 seit dem
19 jahrhundert für viele der grundfehler
überhaupt die grund begründung für
mission
ich denke es gibt zwei ein paar dinge
dabei zu beachten zum einen zur
erinnerung ich habe mich auch bei
fachleuten vergewissert der fans hat
während jahrhunderten überhaupt keine
rolle gespielt
kein roller keine rolle gespielt für das
missverständnis er ist im achten der
1800 1900 hat er wieder bedeutung
gewonnen
das scheint mir auch bezeichnen dass der
vers bedeutung gewonnen hat im
zusammenhang mit der kolonialen
expansion in dem ganzen jahrhunderten
vorher war für die ausleger klar der
fans richtet sich an die apostel und
nach der zeit der post lässt das
abgeschlossen
im matthäus-evangelium hat er eine ganz
bestimmte funktion oder es das matthäus
evangelium so habe ich dass ich das
verstanden richtet sich eine gemeinde
die nicht sicher ist ob dieser jesus
bewegung überhaupt über das volk israel
hinaus
sich ausbreiten darf und matthäus
schreibt sein evangelium für diese
gemeint unterlässt es ja anfangen damit
das sagt da kommen leute die einen stern
gesehen haben eine konstellation die
sind eher angezogen von diesem von
diesem ereignis und finden den
neugeborenen heiland und es hört auf
damit dass der auferstandene ihnen sagt
jetzt geht und setzt euch nicht von von
euch her grenzen
das imperialistische missverständnis des
verses war für matthäus nicht
vorauszusehen errichtete sich eine
gemeinde über keine machtmittel verfügte
die kein geld hat die eine verschwindend
kleine minderheit war und ihnen jetzt
sagen hört man ihr habt so etwas
großartiges geht und geht einfach
überall wo er hinkommt und teilt das mit
den menschen
das war die grundidee und dann sieht das
dann heute also dass weitere historische
eigentlich solche einleitungen in seiner
wirkung wie sehen sie das heute
wie relevant ist heute denn dieses team
und taufen
der glaube an gott ist nicht etwas was
ich einfach nicht behalten und ich
erlebe so gewinnbringend erzählt von
meinen kindern weiter und ich erzähle es
da weiter wo menschen das auch hören ich
habe viele von meinen freunden gerd
gehen gegen keine kirche hat mit gott
nichts am hut gehabt ich habe das
gesprochen der einen anderen weg
interessiert und hat sich dann
eingeklickt in dem glauben dann sagt die
bibel g und erklären was bedeutet jesus
nachzufolgen
und das ist für mich dem moment wo ich
etwas begeistert erzählt gibt von der
reaktion die an und sagen nein dann ist
erledigt und dann respektiere ich dass
das ist wirklich man muss einen neuen
respektieren und die die ja sagen diesen
besuchen die leute einen leute natürlich
mehr was bedeutet dies zu glauben das
ist für mich etwas ganz natürliches
seit genau 20 bei ihnen in ihrer
gemeinschaft diese gedanken sie jetzt
eben gerade auch von herrn schubert
gehört haben nämlich die dieser
rückblick und diese kritische
betrachtung wie der mission befehl in
der geschichte
es ist das ist seine auslegung ich
möchte ganz bewusst in den bereich der
theologie und ich habe auch die
logischste die du kannst alles so drehen
wie du es willst und es gibt jede menge
verschiedene meinungen über bibeltexte
wasser ist etwas sagt ist falsch
ich möchte nur sagen ich habe einen
anderen ansatz ich wir sind eine kirche
wir sind begeistert und wir erzählen den
leuten über jesus die auch offen sind
aus trieren ich habe viele leute den
golfplatz
die kommen jetzt in das eis jetzt
aufgrund von golfspielern was ich habe
nicht die frage gestellten der einsamen
gesagt ich habe die frage genau vor
einer woche gestellt gibt es gott und es
bist du hier wäre mir das und das ist
ganz natürlich erklärt ihnen das was für
mich heißt jesus nachzufolgen ich lade
sie ein ist etwas das hat nicht
aufgehört
okay wir gehen mal einen schritt weiter
und zwar haben sie mir eben herr
schubert ein stichwort gegeben nämlich
die frage ob die mission überhaupt über
das volk israel hinausgehen soll und
mich interessiert jetzt ein ganz
bestimmtes ein ganz bestimmter aspekt in
der mission geschichte nämlich die
judenmission und wie die christlichen
kirchen damit umgegangen sind und heute
auch noch umgehen ist judenmission heute
noch ein thema in der heutigen kirchen
entwicklung und anders gefragt gelten
juden als zu missionieren
das ist das kommt extrem auf die
biologische ausrichtung davon also es
ist immer noch für mahlzeiten in der
evangelikalen ecke ich habe die
bezeichnung nicht so gerne aber da ist
warum haben sie die bezeichnung nicht so
gern weil es eine schwierige
kategorisierung ist ja auch nicht allen
personen gewicht wird erwogen es
beschreibt eine gewisse ausrichtung zum
beispiel des giebels verständnis dass
die ganze bibel wirklich aufnimmt also
ist der evangelikale in ihren augen ist
schwierig eben ich höre schon lange
nicht mehr ich würde sagen er
evangelikale moment bedeutet ja doch
sehr klar in der verkündigung was
richtig und was falsch ist eben was
mission ist was nicht mission ist
was ein jüngerer oder einer jüngeren ist
und was nicht
auch klo mit punktueller bekehrung als
bekehrung ereignissen dann aber doch auf
die nöte der menschen ausgerichtet
kontextualisiert auf die jugendkultur
angepasstes hat auch das neo aus im
gespräch mit dieser kultur und dann aber
doch ein wort und und klar ist auch in
der bibel exegese wo wahrscheinlich wenn
ich heute nicht da eine andere exegese
machen werden gut gehen wir noch einmal
zurück zu fragen sind jüdinnen und juden
ziel christlicher mission ja oder nein
ich würde sagen nicht warum nicht meine
juden und jüdinnen haben auch das
trainiert arische jedes bild komplett
abgelehnt müsste man treibt mich sagen
sie müssten
ziel der christlichen mission seien sie
herr becker ihre kirche hat eine
leitstelle oder eine filiale in tel aviv
was machen sie nicht sein
ja es waren wir schon immer ein
wichtiges land weil tel aviv ist
eigentlich eine große riesen metropole
statt wo die leute von der ganzen welt
sind und dass das modell die art von 18
extremen tel aviv hinein und das wäre
haben wir machen nicht abwegig kirchen
gründung sondern dass eine person die
sagte ich habe meine leidenschaft für
tel aviv dann schauen mir -button wähler
haben sie auch die leidenschaft qualität
und wenn ja dann schicken wir sie aus
unterkühlten die eine church relativ
ganz ganz simpel aber ich wollte einfach
nicht auch heikel wenn gerade in einem
gebiet das ja von religiösen spannungen
seit jeher betroffen ist dann eine
kirche sich neu etabliert die ein gros
sendungsbewussten für mich ist gar
nichts halten solange man immer die
leute respektiert die auch ja oder nein
sagen das ist mein punkt wenn man
einfach hinstellt und sagt glauben jesus
wenn ja super nein ich genau dich ab
dass das ist das was wir verurteilen
sprechen sie mit ideen und juden über
übergeht absolut dass wir absolut nicht
spreche mit allen leuten über jesus
heißen muslims juden alle leute ich
mache da nicht so unterschiede sondern
ich spreche dies weil ich begeistert bin
ist ein teil von mir
ich kann das nicht verleugnen dass ich
dort glaube ich für mich immer noch das
zentrum von meinem leben und darum ist
es mir wichtig dass ich über das auch
spreche aber weil ich begeistert denn
und ich finde denn ich möchte das
bewusst auch betonen für mich ist
mission immer etwas was leute überstülpt
und mit dem haben heute mit der ganzen
bewegung die sollte da geht ja nicht
gleich lieb ist kopf ab und ich finde
wenn man man muss es respektieren wenn
ihr das nicht sieht und dann habe ich
nicht ein problem
aber es gibt auch leute die es auch
sehen jüdinnen und juden sehen das zum
teil anders wir haben hier einen
einspieler aus dem film gottesmänner am
ball und werden uns mal an was rabbiner
josua ins dazu sagt es gibt schon
reibungspunkte auf christlicher seite
aus jüdischer sicht hat es manchmal zu
tun entweder mit jesus oder vielleicht
auch mit dem missionieren also es gibt
bestimmt immer noch einen teil der
christlichen kirche die gerne
judenmission ihren möchten und da sind
wir natürlich sehr dagegen auf der einen
seite ist manchmal die spannung mit
jesus weil wer war jesus genau an wer
war historisch weil aus jüdischer sicht
ist natürlich erst einmal jüdisch und
aus christlicher sicht gibt es natürlich
manche kreise die gerne das jüdische
haus haben möchten und ihnen lieber für
sich christlich sehen wollen also die
jüdischen wurzeln ungern akzeptieren
möchten ja wenn die schuberth sie haben
auch eigentlich die vorstellung dass
teil der mission auch in den
interreligiösen begegnungen im
interreligiösen dialog stattfindet wie
geht nun respekt und anerkennung des
gegenübers zusammen mit einem
wahrheitsanspruch der daneben auch in
einem missverständnis mündet ich glaube
wir können nicht als ich kann als als
christlicher theologen nicht aus der
spannung aussteigen dass ich auf der
einen seite das johannes-evangelium lese
und
dort jesus in einem entscheidenden
moment zu seinen jüngern sagt ich bin
der weg die wahrheit und das leben als
sie ziemlich desorientiert sind
das ist ein satz den man nicht anders
formulieren kann also im moment wo
jemand sagt jesus täter weg da wird die
wahrheit und das leben wird der satz
falsch weil es eine behauptung wird die
er oder sie ja nicht in irgendeiner
weise verifizieren kann also das ist das
was wir als exklusiven wahrheit an
exklusiven anspruch während dem wenn ich
bis jetzt mal simpel zu sagen ich jesus
das sagen höre dann ist es die frage an
mich wie gehst du damit um und auf der
anderen seite ist es paulus der in einem
der schönsten bilder sagt in seinem
großen kapitel über die liebe sagt auf
die liebe kommt es an jetzt erkennen wir
alles stückweise wir sehen in einem
dunklen worte übersetzt in einem spiegel
in einem dunklen wort alles stückweise
und einmal werde ich erkennen wie ich
erkannt in russland bleiben glaube
hoffnung liebe die liebe ist die größte
das heißt ich kam nie darüber hinaus
dass meine erkenntnis der wahrheit sehr
begrenzt ist
ich sehe was ich sehe ich bin in der
schweiz aufgewachsen ich habe ein paar
jahre in angola gelebt und habe mit
mission 21 noch zwei drei andere länder
gesehen aber trotzdem habe ich eine
extrem provinzielle perspektive ich bin
ein mann ich bin nicht münch ich bin
also ich habe verschiedene eigenschaften
die das prägen was ich wahrnehme und
andere blende ich aus ich komm nicht
darum herum und trotzdem halte ich daran
fest dass was ich erkenne ist hat teil
an der wahrheit und darüber bin ich im
gespräch
das bedeutet für mich dieser dialog und
ich kann in einem dialog ja nicht auch
im dialog mit jüdischen nachbarn oder
mit mit muslimischen nachbarn kann ich
ja nicht dann einfach sagen okay
ich will dich nicht schockieren darum es
erzähle ich dir nicht was jesus christus
für mich bedeutet aber sobald ich das
verbinde mit einem anspruch du solltest
eigentlich so werden wie ich bevor
richtig als richtigen menschen
akzeptieren
dort wird wäre ich sehr problematisch
das ist dass du sagst mit der pistole
oder das geht ja nicht das geht aber
geht man dann einen dialog auf augenhöhe
also ich bin selbst seit 20 jahren in
vielen interreligiösen dialogs gremien
tätig und dieser anspruch der soll auf
augenhöhe stattfinden der schließt ja
eigentlich aus dass eine der seiten eine
der beteiligten einen höheren
geltungsanspruch hat als in anderen
findet man sich in einem interreligiösen
dialog denn überhaupt auf augenhöhe
ich würde sagen auf jeden fall der
dialog bedingte berater dass man sich
der eigenen identität bewusst ist in
meinem sinne auch meine christlichen
identität und so ist genau der
interreligiöse dialog mit jemandem der
sich seine muslimischen seiner jüdischen
identität bewusst ist auf augenhöhe und
der dialog beginnt ja schon die
augenhöhe ist und dieses kein dialog
oder und das wie martin huber sagt dass
ich würd ich am dialog selber denke ich
darf finden auch veränderungsprozesse
statt und da findet ist für mich mich
sie uns theologisch gesehen reich gottes
statt weil darauf riede um verständnis
und freundschaft und gerechtigkeit
entstehen kann
gerade eben da und wenn es nicht auch in
höhe ist es kein glück wenn sie von
ihrer begeisterung eben erzählt haben
und sie möchten dass anderen mitteilen
sind sie darauf angewiesen dass andere
ihnen zuhören wie sieht denn das
umgekehrt aus wenn andere menschen aus
anderen religionen mit ihrer
begeisterung über ihren eigenen glauben
sprechen haben sie dann auch dieses
große gehört dass sie sich ihrerseits
von ihren zuhörern gewünschten absolut
mal im leben muss man immer zu hören man
hat er zwei uhren bekommen nur einem und
da sagte man muss doppelt so viel hören
wie man wie man spricht dann zu hören
ist immer wichtig im leben weil dann mit
dem kann auch dinge reflektieren und ich
sagen
nur schon ich predige muss ich nur schon
auf das hören noch leute sagen wie kommt
das bei ihnen an
was löst es aus vielleicht habe ich eine
gruppe vergessen oder mit diesem
beispiel habe ich zum beispiel die
frauen verletzt und dann ist es nur
schon das zuhören mehr gewicht das ich
finde ich selber dinge leere
das heißt auch für mich ist augenhöhe
hat mit dem zu tun ich respektiere jeden
mensch als ein original und das hat für
mich das hat für mich diese augenhöhe
mal was zu tun
ich kann im gespräch sogar der sein der
recht hat und dennoch man schaut nie
runter sondern man sieht gegenüber immer
als aus ein geschäft von gott und das
gebührt respekt jeder mensch gebührt
respekt egal was deine hautfarbe
background of seven das eine
grundhaltung in meinen augen
sie haben eben noch das stichworte der
frauen gegeben etwas nie aufgefallen ist
bei der ganzen auseinandersetzung mit
der mission die missionare waren im
allgemeinen männer die großen bücher die
bei christliche mission geschrieben
wurden waren männer
wo bleiben denn die frauen in der
mission erstaunlicherweise ich doch
immer noch ziemlich im background hing
hinter und in afrika gibt es zb ansätze
von feministische mission feministische
missions- theologie es ist aber sehr
vage finde ich einfach was ich gefunden
habe bis jetzt die feministische
perspektive im bereich mission hat aber
spannende ansätze
gerade diese kontextualisierung und
kontext und in konturierung ist sehr
stark ist das genau die
kontextualisierung dass man ganz auf den
kontext der menschen eingeht was die
sprache den kontext einer gruppe eines
netzwerks eines landes eine region
lernen und die feministische missions-
theologie stellt da genau auch kritische
folgen sagt wenn ihr da einfach
kontextualisiert sieht ihr dann auch
dann haben sie vor allem wieder keine
stimme oder also wo es
kontextualisierung mich wo ist es
wichtig den frauen eine stimme zu geben
hörte unsere geschichte also da kommt
die fed der feministischen aspekt rhein
im sinn von
habt gehör verschaffen wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe heiß contexta listerien
auch oder drückt sich das auch etwa in
formen aus wie bestimmte formen von
kirche also erlebnis kirche die auf
mountainbiker oder auf skater wie sie es
in ihrer arbeit auch erwähnt ramsgate
kirche dieser form wie sie es ansprechen
zum beispiel habe ich habe hier die
letzten sechs jahre dazu geforscht wie
kirche in ein netzwerk in einen kontext
reingeht zum beispiel in not brettfeld
viele jugendlichen aus sozial
schwierigen gebieten das paper oder in
der schweiz die heavy-metal-szene um
2000 kirche in verschiedenen szenen mit
werken
das ist hier bei uns die frage von
missionen kontext in afrika gibt es
anders haben und jetzt kommt die
feministischen perspektive gehabt wo ihr
geht welchen menschen gibt hier keine
stimme wegen der kontextualisierung was
müssen nicht befragen sie haben wo
übergeht die ungleichheiten sagt da
sieht man dann wieder diese kritischen
aspekt baby ganz wichtig sind wenn man
sich zum thema der mission gedanken
macht und auch so die weltweite
situation sich vor augen hält dann
merken wir es gibt gesellschaften
nämlich die meisten gesellschaften die
sich immer noch weitgehend religiös
verstehen und es gibt den ausnahmefall
europa und dort auf und nordamerika der
sich sehr säkular versteht wie verändert
sich jetzt mission je nachdem ob sie in
einer religiösen gesellschaft
stattfindet also beispielsweise in einem
islamischen land
und wie verhält es sich umgekehrt mit
einer säkularen gesellschaft wie wie
sehen sie das
ich glaube dass mission tatsächlich in
einem land in dem grundsätzlich ein
selbstverständnis darüber versteht dass
religion ein teil des ein teil der
lebenswirklichkeit ist über die wir auch
miteinander kommunizieren können dass es
einfacher ist einfach diese die weil
weiter gesprächs gegenwehr der
kommunikations gegenstand religion nicht
sofort wie irgendetwas
peinliches betrachtet wird es ist ein
normales gesprächsthema in den jahren in
denen wir in angola lebten das war noch
die zeit des real existierenden
sozialismus in einem tango la wo die
offizielle staatsstruktur ebene der
historische materialismus war aber es
war vollkommen selbstverständlich dass
man auch wenn man in einer warteschlange
darauf wartete dass man sein fahrrad
wieder bekam oder so über fragen der
kirchenzugehörigkeit reden konnte und
die einen waren in einer kirche die
andere nicht und es war niemand peinlich
berührt und in einer situation wie in
der schweiz vor allem wo ich immer noch
den eindruck habe sobald das thema
sobald man auf das thema glaube kommt
werden alle ein bisschen gespannt und
finden ist alles sofort ein bisschen
peinlich
man fühlt sich sofort ein bisschen nackt
ausgezogen die frage wie hältst du es
mit gott ist eigentlich ein so ein so
ein affront ich darf sie als paar
stellen das ist der vorteil meiner rolle
aber ich meine man käme ja nie auf die
frage wann kommt nicht auf die idee im
zug ein gespräch über glauben zu hören
während die leute ihre sämtlichen
gesundheitsproblem oder ihre ihre ihre
probleme in der partnerschaft lauthals
diskutieren
das ist wirklich ein das ist ein
spezielles phänomen das zwingt uns auch
denke ich darüber nachzudenken wie wir
wie wir jetzt als kirchen eine
kommunikation pflegen die diese
hemmungen er und nimmt aber zugleich
achten wie unter wandelt darf ich den
haag ich werde momentan etwas
populistisch plädieren dass wir haben
zwei große tabus in unserer gesellschaft
und das ist der tod das eine das erlebt
man in vorarlberg immer das andere ist
die persönliche spiritualität und wie
gesagt gesundheitsthemen oder sexualität
oder was auch immer sie eigentlich keine
tabus mehr aber sobald fragen nach
persönlichen glauben glaubens fähigkeit
spiritualität auf kommt bricht sein
schweigen aus betroffenheit aber ist das
nicht auch die folge der säkularisierung
auf die will ja eigentlich stolz sind
als errungenschaft in europa in dem hier
schafft haben gerade diese fragen zwar
nicht zu tabuisieren aber zumindest
derart in den privaten bereich zu
verbringen oder einzulagern sind doch
keine das ist kein erfolg das ist ein
rückschritt weil du kannst nicht auf
einen tod verdrängen als wird es der
nicht existiere
und dann ist jede verkrampft wenn jemand
stirbt und sagen der glaube ist
privatsache während jede person sich die
frage stellten das habe ich schon am
anfang gesagt woher komme ich wohin gehe
ich was ich nach dem tod jeder mensch
auch in europa stellt sich diese frage
und darum ist eben für mich man hat das
verdrängt weil man im moment einfach nur
noch am besten hauptsache stimmt für
mich so der social media' generation
alles muss jetzt und ich und das zentrum
und das kann man schon verdrängen aber
man kann sich immer verdrängen
wenn ich sage das ist normale prognose
ein pendel bewegt sich immer auf die
eine seite ist extrem und geht in die
kirchengeschichte wieder auf die andere
seite
das heißt es ist wenn man auf eine frage
der zeit wo menschen merken wir haben
alles materielle und geht's mir gut
und dann kommt die frage von der und
jetzt was gibt es noch und dann kommt
die frage wieder herkommen werde ich und
das ist das sehen vom leben und die der
frage welche leute moment aus aber man
kann nicht immer der frage ausweichen
dann ist unser gemeinschaft unser job
als fahrer ist erneuten da mut zu machen
diese tabus aufzubrechen weil
irgendjemand muss es machen
ich sage wenn wir in der kirche schon
schweigen dann schweigen wir alle und
jeder gesagt einmal nur eingezogen ist
nach lucien wenn ihr mich nicht anbietet
werden die steine mir zu rufen
das ist für mich ein krasses beispiel
bei jesus sagt dann will ich auch andere
dinge unternehmen um den menschen zu
zeigen wer bin ich also gott hat er
viele optionen gut wir gehen noch einen
schritt weiter und fragen uns nach den
spielregeln und strategien was ist
zulässig und was ist nicht zulässig wir
hatten schon
wir haben schon einiges gehört ich frage
aber trotzdem ganz ganz klar muss man
eigentlich mission transparent machen
oder darf sie implizit mitlaufen
was ist da ihre haltung
wirklich zu fragen was ist mit der
mission ist einst für eine gerechte
struktur dann kann das durchaus implizit
mitlaufen wenn wenn mission verkündigung
ist verkündigung ist ist es schon
explizit deshalb ist mir das breite
missverständnis so wichtig weil je
nachdem bei welchen punkte mission ich
bin ist auch die frage noch implizit und
explizit wesentlich um gegeben
ich denke dort wo es um notlagen von
menschen geht ist die das explizit
extreme wesentlich wir haben ja jetzt
gerade aktuell die situation dass viele
flüchtlinge aus anderen weltgegenden zu
uns nach europa kommen
und da stellt sich natürlich die frage
nach der mission auch wieder neue sie
herr schubert sie hatten zwei
afghanische jugendliche aufgenommen
jetzt schon wie lange leben fünf monate
fünf monate inwiefern ist bei ihnen ich
nehme an dass in muslime wenn sie aus
afghanistan kommen
wie gehen sie damit glaubensfragen um
sind dass die jugendlichen die sie
darauf ansprechen oder kommt dass er von
ihrer seite beides sie sie sind zu uns
gekommen wir haben im moment wie wir
gelernt haben
sprachlich miteinander zu weil das am
anfang viele quasi sprechen fließend
dari und wir sprechen verschiedene
europäische sprache aber dem maß wie wir
miteinander sprechen können machen wird
machen wir das auch behutsam zum thema
sie wissen dass ich froh bin ob es
statthaft war als ihren anfang das
erklärt haben ihn zu sagen ich meine art
muller das müssen jetzt islamist
spezialisten sagt ob ich das darf aber
sie haben verstanden was meine was meine
rolle ist
wir haben wir gehören zu dieser schlecht
aussterbenden spezies die ein tischgebet
spricht wir haben das weiter gepflegt
weil wir für weil wir auch gemerkt haben
für sie ist es ist das ganz
selbstverständlich formen des religiösen
kassen hatten diese jugendlichen
zuvorkommt
akte zu nicht den filmischen
gemeinschaftlich am land das kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen
also so wie ich sie wahrnehmen kommen
sie aus einer familie die eine gewisse
kulturelle religiöse praxis hat
sicherlich die jetztzeit ihr miteinander
sprechen märchen wird sie eher skeptisch
sind gegenüber den sehr radikalen
bewegung und umgekehrt versuchen wir
auch ernst zu nehmen was ihre
bedürfnisse sind das ob jetzt sagen wir
möchten kontakt zu einer moschee oder
jetzt kommt die frage des ramadan die
werden wir mit ihnen klären müssen
wir werden wir werden jetzt wir haben
kontakt mit einem aufgaben der schon
lange in der schweiz lebt den wird den
wir und unterstützung bitten und gehen
denn diese jugendlichen in die moschee
das ist die frage wie weit wie weit sie
haben einmal einer hat einmal das
bedürfnis geäußert das ist das wieder
eingeschlafen also dass das wir wir
müssen das miteinander wie heraus aber
sie gehen nicht so weit dass sie sagen
schaut ich weiß ihr seid muslime und in
basel gibt s die um die um die moschee
also wenn ihr gehen wollt dann geht doch
ich habe kontakt aufgenommen zu muss
zusehen dass er bekommt konkret dann
meine kollegen gefragt die ehre im
interreligiösen dialog auf die sind mit
wem kann ich kontakt aufnehmen und ich
habe sozusagen ein 1 1 1 1 setting
vorbereitet dass wenn sie sagen wir
möchten gehen dann weiß ich mit wem ich
sind kontakt bringen kann
meerbeke ihre kirche kommt ja auch immer
wieder mal in unter verdacht
gerade kürzlich sozusagen bei
flüchtlingen zu missionieren die
flüchtlinge die kommen kommen oftmals
aus muslimischen ländern aber oftmals
systemen in denen sie eigentlich zu viel
an religiosität erlebt haben und das
auch vielleicht gewissermaßen durch
repression erlebt haben sind denn die
überhaupt offen für jegliche form von
religiosität oder sagen lasst uns jetzt
einfach mal in free kann nicht für alle
sprechen aber generell müsse man muss
uns bewusst seine leute kommen auf den
ländern wurde die brüder quasi
weggeschaut haben kommt nach europa und
seien christen sie sie aufnehmen
eine religion musik oder umgebracht wird
darf man klartext zu sprechen und das
öfter bei vielen leuten schon mal das
herz quasi warum nimmt uns auf eine
andere religion dann kommt das gleiche
prinzip wie bei jedem mensch wenn sie
offen sind dann lade ich sie ein sehen
sie abwesend dann lasse ich sie
es ist nicht das gleiche prinzip egal ob
flüchtlinge oder oder was auch immer
wenn leute ja sagen lade ich sie einfach
wenn sie nein respektiere ich
ihre wahrnehmung und viele von diesen
modems die lebenden gaben gar nicht
praktisch gelaufen
auf dem papier sind sie moslems sie
haben viele von denen gar nicht mehr
eben diesen hintergrund was es ganz ganz
auch fest aus gelebt haben
und die kommt die kommen viele von denen
kommen in die kirche und uns sind
begeistert über diese art wieder wie wir
gottesdienst erleben die alten und die
alten gar nicht es gibt immer zwei
reaktionen
wir hatten ja und nein reden wir noch
einen moment über das wesen des
missionars es fehlt ein etwas großes
wort aber schauen wir uns einen
einspieler nämlich aus dem film gott und
seine helfer von katyn installiert auf
wiesen die revision wie mag man alte
vater oma dora wald sind und dort hannig
wisst dass ich letzte ausflug mit der
ältere der tanz christ und als die
sanitäter bringen
sie kann uns ins kind aussprachen und
älter sind in usa und sehr an firma
umkehrt obwohl mir geschrieben haben und
dank wenn sie sich umkehrt hat und uns
gesagt hatte
er war es verkehrt und hat dank wir
machen das nicht
ich habe es danke frida gold ist mit
zwölf geschwister die super
der tat oder vater sie auf trab
mit vater uhr bereits ab den
briefkontakt gar und der zeit
verstrichen sich ihr freund sie geben
die eigene auto wurde erzählt frieda gut
ihm das mobilität und sagte den 12
und der annie die tagebücher klasse und
auf jeder dritte sieht der hec kaiser wo
sind unsere lieben kinder was machen
unsere lieben kinder und hättest der
ältere bub noch mehr mögen dass sie am
anfang mit begriffen was mir durch macht
dann hat es mich wahnsinnig für peru
fixie für ein potenter keine kinder mehr
software stellen
ja ist doch eine sehr berührende aussage
oder geschichte die diese frau erzählt
und da stellt sich doch die frage wie
ist das wesen eines missionars mir kommt
es hier jetzt doch sehr radikal
eigentlich entgegen dass bis hinauf zur
selbstaufgabe und aufgabe der nächsten
familienmitglieder erklärten dass also
ich würde sagen da sind wir noch in eine
andere zeit wurde
und da ist die frage der legitimation
für mich ganz stark 200 jahre zurück
sondern das ist die generation unserer
urgroßeltern viele genau also da wir die
ich große anfragen stellen um die
familie an den familienzusammenhalt
meine vor gewesen heißt es heute
missionarin zu sein und schlussendlich
klar ich sind wir dass irgendwo alle
obwohl ich auch gehört habe dass gewisse
diesem begriff ablehnen aber wenn wir
eine religion angehören und davon
überzeugt sind sind wird das alle und so
würde ich sagen die qualität der mission
ist vielleicht gerade dialog bereit
schafft der respekt gegenüber dem
anderen
die offenheit von anderen zu lernen
die selbstreflexion im sinne auch der
eigenen identität der eigenen religiösen
identität zu kennen die es auch ins
gespräch zu bringen ist sich keine
machtausübung und personalisierung noch
mal zurück zur frage der der
selbstaufgabe aufgabe wir hatten wir
waren im gespräch wie diese wendung mit
einem anderen gast einer eines großen
missionarischen werkes der hat mich
lässt schlussendlich abgesagt weil er
sagte ich bin in heiklen ländern in
geschlossenen gesellschaften als
missionar unterwegs und ich kann und
will mich nicht
also eher gefährdet sich und sein leben
für seine mission ist das für sie heute
noch nachvollziehbar ja also es ist für
mich nachvollziehbar dass jemand dass
jemand sagt ich ich ich bin ergriffen
von etwas und ich glaube dass das dieses
evangelium paris schreibt das einmal das
ist kraft zum leben und es ist kraft zum
leben die ich nicht für mich behalten
will
ich bringe die ob ich die jetzt
ausgerechnet in situationen bringen muss
wo es extrem gefährlich ist da kann man
die frage stelle auf der anderen seite
nötigt mir das respekt ab dass jemand
sagt ich bringe das dorthin weil das
evangelium sich immer wieder ins in
systemen als zu passiv erwiesen hat und
und autoritäre systeme gesprengt hat ich
meine die die wir haben jetzt immer von
der kolonialen mission gesprochen weil
das sehr schnell miteinander
identifiziert wird aber man darf nicht
vergessen dass im widerstand gegen den
kolonialismus und frauen mit den
befreiungsbewegungen gegen die
kolonialmächte es oft schülerinnen und
schüler aus mission schulen waren die
aufgrund des evangeliums begriffen haben
dass sie
für die freiheit kämpfen sollen also und
das dass diese subversiv und befreiende
kraft des evangeliums weitergegeben wird
man sagt da hast du etwas was dir hilft
in einem extrem repressiven system zu
überleben und die sogar kraft gibt sich
dagegen zu wehren
das scheint mir durchaus legitim
wir sind bereits am ende der sendung
einsatz möchte ich von ihnen allen noch
hören nämlich zu der frage wann war für
sie ein persönliches erlebnis einer
geglückten mission jupiter eine
geglückte mission war ich dann etwa
nicht happy bin ich bin jedem sonntag
werde die letzte predigt gehalten habe
ich sehe menschen denen laufen tränen
runter weil sie dann erstmal eine kirche
sehen aus anderen menschen hier habt ihr
handy so verschränkter nächster geht gar
nicht rein das ist kirche die einen
sagen ja und dann sind so berührt in der
gleichen billig und jan und sagen e mail
und ich komme nie mehr was sie mir bei
zunächst jeden sonntag jedenfalls prima
mühle wenn im leben von einzelnen aus
unterdrückung lebendigkeit entstehen
kann also wenn menschen individuell
gefördert bewegt ermutigt ermächtigt
werden sich selbst zu sein und ihren
glauben wirklich dass auch ihm ist zu
leben einen satz von ihnen herr robert
warum war ihr letztes geglücktes
missions- erlebnis die schwierige frage
was heißt geglückt ich werde auch
ähnlich sagen wenn wenn ich merke es
gelingt in der art ich mache jetzt
fahren wir durch sprache ausbau ich
predige viel und wenn ich merke menschen
wissen ich bin gemeint und ich bin
erleichtert gott
wunderbar ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei ihnen allen sabrina müller leo
bickel in die stube herzlichen dank
geisteswissenschaften
allen voran die philosophie ist ohne
zeitverschwendung das hören wir auch bei
uns immer mal wieder carlos frenkel
professor für jüdische und arabische
philosophie tritt an das gegenteil zu
beweisen
er ist jetzt gleich gast in der
sternstunde philosophie